Pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous et
activez la petite cloche.
Bonjour les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Si vous demandez à quelqu'un
dans la rue de quelle couleur sont les carottes,
cette personne vous répondra
sans hésitation,oranges.
Il y a quelques milliers d'années,
pourtant, durant l'Antiquité,
on vous aurait
fait une toute autre réponse
car à l'époque les carottes
étaient blanches.
Elles ressemblaient
à une sorte de panais rabougri
et probablement qu'en vous répondant,
votre interlocutrice ouvotre interlocuteur
aurait esquissé une petite grimace.
Les carottes étaient alors sauvages,
toutes maigrichonnes,
très dures, légèrement épicées
et âpres au goût.
Du coup, nos ancêtres préféraient
consommerles graines de carottes
plutôt que la racine.
Les premières carottes de couleurs
sont sortiesde terre
il y a environ 1000 ans,
du côté de l'Afghanistan.
Elles sont jaunes ou pourpres.
Petit àpetit,
leur culture et leur consommation
s'étendent aux pays voisins.
Elles débarquent sur les tables de
France, d'Allemagne et des Pays-Bas au 14e siècle.
À ce stade toujours pas de carotte orange.
Lespremières voient le jour
deux siècles plus tard
dans l'un des pays d'accueil : les Pays-Bas.
Elle estvraisemblablement issue
du croisement de plusieurs variétés de carottes jaunes.
Son succès est
immédiat.
Sûrement un peu à cause de sa couleur.
L'orange est, en effet, celle des princes des Pays-Bas
mais pas seulement. Cette carotte est aussi très charnue
et plus sucrée que les carottes blanches.
Etpuis à la différence des carottes pourpres,
elle ne déteint pas dans l'eau de cuisson
et ne colorepas les autres aliments.
Du coup, quand cette carotte orange débarque,
c'est un peu râpé pour lesautres.
Aujourd'hui, plusieurs variétés anciennes et colorées
refont surface et sont disponibles surles marchés.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'elles sont
toutes excellentes pour la santé :
la carotte orangecontient du carotène,
le pigment qui est responsable de sa couleur.
Un précurseur de la vitamine B.
C'estaussi un antioxydant comme les anthocyanes
qui colorent les carottes pourpres.
Elles contiennentaussi de la vitamine B1, B2
et de la vitamine C.
Elle se mangent en toute saison car elle se récoltent
du mois de mai au mois de février suivant.
Elle se croquent crues ou cuites,
se mangent entières ourâpées
et on en fait aussi un excellent jus.
Et en plus, on dit que ça rend aimable.
Tiens, il faudra que je
creuse cette histoire. Allez santé !
Ça sent bon.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux.
Pour les plus gourmands en voici d'autres et pour
ne rien rater, abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.